I just realized something what you know
that's sang from George Carlin think
about stoop how stupid the average
person is yeah I realize half a more
stupider than that
I just realized think about how boring
life is now realize half of all the news
stories you've read have been
sensationalized the world is
substantially more boring than you think
it is so true
like there's nothing going on these
places nothing is happening what if we
are in a simulation but like the kid
turned on the Sims and just like went to
college and his computer is just on auto
mode to spend suspend for like the next
several hundred screen savers on we are
screensaver is kovat we are a game of
the sims yeah
operating on some kids computer and he
went off to college and it's sitting in
his room and his parents just leave it
on suspend or someone started playing
play again at the same time and then it
like the computer just running a
background together just run it we're
running in the background on some old
blast damage from plague inc yeah it's
slowly going its boring though you know
like all of these news stories that come
out they've sensationalized everything
there was that there was there was a
video III covered this a few years ago
there's a video of someone like a car
blowing up in Iraq I think and then a
bunch of people run in and then lay down
and start rolling around on the ground
and then journalists run up and start
filming it like they're the ones who got
hit by like the people who were on the
ground rolling around like they got hit
by an explosion when this I swear to god
it's like I have the video the explosion
happens they all run and lay down isn't
rolling on the ground Wow there's tons
of videos like this here's what's crazy
about it though
you don't know who staged the video
right so let's use it let's use a more
contemporary example there's those
videos of the nurses or the people
wearing scrubs in the middle of the
street right and there's the woman hang
out of the car screaming go to China if
you want communism yeah that video goes
the photo goes viral no one knows who
these doctors nurses are it turns out
some people have to have claimed they
have evidence they're not really was
staged but then another video comes out
where you see two people wearing scrubs
on a corner and some woman's filming
them she's like what are you doing and
they walk in the street stand infront of
the car staged a photo with some
journalist and then they run off and she
goes I caught you at stage that caught
you yeah I remember everybody thinks
that video is
legit but both of them could be staged
that's true yeah so a lot of people were
questioning whether that video of the
woman catching them staging it was
staged itself it's all one big stage
dude everyone is just lying and and
pushing propaganda to gain political
power you know that's what it's all
about
we're just simply there 15 minute fame
window they're like oh look I'm on the
news now yes man
yeah it's war it's it's like it's like I
was saying before it when it comes to
like what's the purpose of actual war
like shooting and stuff to take over
someone else's property basically take
control of something take control
resources territory shut down a certain
ideology retaliation revenge it's all
about like you being in control of
something but you don't need to fight to
get that anymore if you can trick people
that's true so now it's just the the
Internet is a constant state of civil
war yeah this was really frustrating
because you know for those who they're
listening we were like trying to figure
out what to talk about and I'm like you
know we did talk about I did a segment
on this already then I saw that James
O'Keefe was like we got a new emails
like confirmed and I'm like what you
definitely talked about this but weird
we're just all like the news repeat
itself every day every single day I'll
see like 10 stories where it's like
Trump is disagreeing with someone else
and I'm like how is that news yeah like
if you ever had a job
have you ever disagreed with someone at
that job is that news apparently and
then you see these pundits on Twitter
everything is like semantics without
calling anybody yet you'll see someone
say something like Trump is being
ridiculous and I'm like bro that's not
an idea that's not an argument you are
not arguing anything yeah what am I
supposed to do with this and that's the
News's like the the front-page story
right now is apparently like what's
what's her name Caylee McKenna knee yeah
she told the media that they wrote fake
news and I'm like like I know it feels
good to see her be like you guys put
published fake news to and it's like and
yeah you know why is that the front page
like why I shouldn't say front page cuz
I'm not referring to yeah it's also not
shot that's fine too though but I'm just
saying like the news is just every day
like dude it's all reality TV we're
literally
the real president of America that's the
show it's called real presidents of the
United States real journalists of
America and it's like watching a
journalist stand up and be like you sir
Orin are an absurd man and well don't
you tell me your fake news and it's like
WWE brought to life you know yeah dude
it's just and I'm trying to weed through
this and figure out if something's
actually happening yeah but I think I
think what were what we're in for
some things happen sometimes things
happen you know I mean like a thing
might happen like this like today
Project Veritas did some real reporting
and now there's a thing yes but
typically things don't happen and I
remember hearing stories of like the BBC
they used to like shut off at night and
I would say things like there's no news
that was it really
yeah yeah I never heard of oh yeah and
there was like radio reports of like
there's no news today carry on
just play music life's good what today
carry on it's all doing life you know
yeah do you think nothing happened today
there is no news for the day of you know
whatever so what we get now is like what
did Don Lemon do man that the guy is the
worst
it's you know I hope he looks into the
camera he goes Donald Trump why do you
not like Obama he's because he's better
looking than you
and it's like this it's so annoying I
get this really long drawn-out he pauses
for like five seconds in between each
sentence I saw it trending I just closed
myself to watch is like Michelle Obama
more attractive than your wife seriously
that's the kind of stuff he was saying
yeah yep and I'm watching this and I
know exactly what it is it is not
directed at Trump it's hilarious it's
not it's not for Trump at all uh it's
for the audience who hates Trump and
they know it that's so true I'm just so
sick of I have I'm not saying he's
hilarious it's it's sad really yeah
that's what they're reporting it's like
the main thing it's not reporting it's
not yes it's all means technically
that's what he's doing but it's an
opinion race a TV show called the real
journalists of America yeah and it's
like just you don't man I'm just done
just take down lemon and take Hannity
you put him in a house together
lock the door for 30 days and put some
cameras in there and watch what happens
and that's what you want isn't it this
is what you want right you know what are
you not entertained yeah this is not
enough for you how about we do that is
that why we are here I mean actually
notes funny is is I think vice actually
did something like this they took a
proud boy and auntie fun like made him
sit down and talk okay yeah it's it's
like this is really this is what people
want man they want to see what happen no
I'm really interested I'm kind of
curious it was actually kind of bad in
my opinion and I think that if a guy got
up and left
oh really you know what were they
arguing or was it just like yeah totally
totally totally we're okay you know what
I just realized it we're done talking
we're done just take Don Lemon and John
Hanning boxing match there you go
that'll satisfy for you right no Rachel
Maddow and John any Laura Ingraham and
Rachel Maddow because you got to have
like no but what I mean is when Don
Lemon goes on TV and he's like troupe
he's a bum a better looking than you I'm
like dude you know what he's doing
yeah he's not talking to Trump he wants
all of the people who hate Trump to go
oh oh man did you see Don Lemon - he
just he just don't Trump damn boy that's
what they want that's what it is that's
so entertaining that you do that it is
the lowest of low brow so why bother
talking anymore just man put him in the
boxing ring and then people gonna be
like yeah hit him hit him that's what we
want to see right I would I would prefer
that over the regular news you know you
know I'm actually really happy to see
this expose from Project Veritas cuz the
other the other story and I will just
talk about it we'll just jump right into
it
op-ed from the New York Times is what I
covered on my main channel what is it we
believe you tar read Joe Biden did it oh
my god this from anyway this is so
stupid
yeah oh mylanta so at this point
everything's fake everyone's lying why
should anybody care you're the crazy
thing about it is though it's like
idiocracy yeah you see their movie of
course for those that haven't seen the
movie a movie
it's another that's about five hundred
years in the future the general idea
it's from Mike Judge smart dude the the
idea is that
evolution is just rewarding those who
produced the most so people who are
smart aren't surviving you know they're
like waiting too long on having kids and
then dumb people's having tons of kids
and then eventually the future has just
tons of really dumb people he got his
general premise wrong but his picture of
the future kind of right like the
premise isn't that people are having
that stupid people have too many kids
it's a good idea the premise is that our
luxury makes us soft and afraid and weak
and we you know it's actually there's
you have you seen every episode of the
next generation I think so yeah you see
you sir have now do you see the one
where the planet is trying to kidnap
Wesley and all the kids from the
enterprise yeah so they have a computer
system that takes care of all of their
needs so they have no idea how to
survive and the solar radiation or the
radiation damage from their planetary
shields is slowly you know killing them
it's radiation poisoning so then they
start to like take kids or whatever but
they've lived for so long with
everything or Wally's a good example too
you know a bunch of big fat people
floating around on chairs everything is
taken care of for them yeah
they end up becoming the end up becoming
weak and in an unable so this is what we
have now we have politics that has
become WWE everything's a lie people
just want to win they don't care about
principles and these people are going to
be jamming the you know the square pegs
of the round hole in terms of our
economic policy and there's nothing we
can do about it because the people who
are voting are the people who like
watching the mud wrestling they want it
they want to see you know the the Don
Lemon guy fight the conservative guy and
want me rolling out of the mud
Jersey Shore was a huge hit people love
making fun of it and watching it and
Real Housewives of whatever city where
we're getting live again we're getting
president Kanye you think so definitely
no I don't know about definitely I
wouldn't be surprised I mean he
surprised the Kardashians man they know
how to play the game do you ever listen
to his rant in the concert but he like
went crazy supposedly a while ago I
don't know how long ago but he's like up
on this stage and he's like the
government lied to you the big pharma
lied to you and he's he's just yelling
all these you know cuz
see things to the to the crowd and
everyone's like yeah but then like he
disappeared for a while and it was like
he came back and he's like now
everything's cool everything's cool
[Laughter]
somebody the mountain they're lying I
feel like he knows he knows he like got
into the in the Millionaire's Club and
then they were like oh yeah Kayne come
on here look at all these secrets we
know yup and he's like what what no no
no no no no and then like went nuts and
then somehow it's like that the Chinese
reported the Chinese doctor no the
reporter I think who disappeared for two
months and then he's like everything's
wonderful
China's great China is great it's like
we know what happens like wait a minute
well so it's on yeah I do switched in
there thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you